Dustin is with us in Fort Myers Florida
hi Dustin welcome to the Dave Ramsey
show hey Dave that's a meal to talk to
you I just started listening to you
Bernie no first of the year so they're
gonna help I'm on board pretty good I'm
still trying to get my budget straight
and everything was just started like I
said and I'm engaged someone getting
married pretty soon she's got multiple
credit cards she's pretty good at
managing her credit she's a good
follower as you say but uh I'm trying to
get her to get rid of him once we get
married I really trying to pressure it
now but she kind of wants me to save up
the money to take up for the lack of the
credit cards before she gets really
serious what do you think I should do
there okay when are y'all getting
married I'm thinking beginning of next
year maybe this year just kind of
depends on we're not doing anything
crazy expensive or anything okay so you
really undecided is what you're saying
okay all right yeah it sound like I'm
not personal around pretty much as the
third listen to your kind of wanted to
go on to you but uh I'm thinking about
bringing a little closer to probably
this year yeah okay some more well the
thing on the hold are you two we're both
said well I'm 31 she's 30
okay all right that's Rachel cruises age
my daughter okay
and so if my daughter or son-in-law were
not married and came to me you know and
ask me the exact same question here's
exactly what I would tell them the
number one cause of fights and a
marriage and the number one cause of
divorce is over money yep and all of the
data points all the research tells us
that there are four things that you need
to be in agreement on before marriage
and if you are you have a very high
probability of a successful marriage and
every one of these you drop out you
lower the prop
ability the most important one is the
biggest one that everybody fights about
money we need to be in agreement on
money we need to be in agreement about
kids
like are we having kids how many
probably and how are we going to treat
them are we going to make them behave or
the inmates going to run the asylum and
parenting style so pick kids number two
number three is in-laws every family has
crazy in it and how are you going to
deal with it as a couple and you've got
to decide that ahead of time and you can
look across that and say well we know
so-and-so is a problem well let's go
ahead and talk about how we're going to
deal with so-and-so when they try to
interfere in our lives because everybody
has that somewhere in their family some
more than others but everybody's got one
at least the last thing is being an
agreement on religion and so if you're
in agreement on religion and you're in
agreement on how to deal with extended
family and deal with the in-laws and
you're in agreement on kids and you're
in agreement on money you have a very
high statistical probability of staying
married a long time because those four
covered just about everything in life
and that matters anyway so you know what
I would always instruct anyone to do is
also see I'm a practical guy so I study
this stuff and go okay how can I stack
the deck in my favor in a world where
marriages fall apart every day right and
so I'm gonna get those things dealt with
the other thing I found out is a six
month or so engagement length is ideal
getting married six days after you met
someone obviously brings problems in
most cases but getting married six years
later says you can't you don't know
whether you know pain or get off the
ladder so you know you need to know
something's wrong there too so that kind
of thing is there the there's exceptions
but by and large you know a good length
of an engagement a healthy length of an
engagement
the other thing the other one is if you
want to stack it in your favor is in
depth detail pre-marriage counseling sit
down with a pastor or a marriage
counselor and pay them and go to four or
five sessions where you deal with your
childhood and how that's going to affect
your family of origin how that's going
to affect how you guys are going to be
married and vice versa can you possibly
imagine what my children would have said
in the pre marriage counseling about
their family of origin
there was plenty of drama to talk about
so it's good you got to get all this
stuff out man you got to deal with it
upfront because you're coming into you
know you are marrying her family whether
you want to or not and definitely
everything we get along on and we get
along with the money yeah so all of that
all that said you don't get along on the
money you're not an agreement on the
money you're playing back and forth
you've got new information you're
starting to get a little bit wired up
about it she's been trying to do a
typical American crap and that's managed
her credit and stayed in debt and kept
the credit cards around as if somehow
that's smart and she are playing Russian
roulette with a financial tool and it's
going to it's going to get you guys so
does that mean you don't marry her no
but you means you guys have some work to
do on that issue so if you'll go to pre
marriage counseling I will include in
your pre marriage counseling the two of
you as an engaged couple going through
Financial Peace University as my guest
okay and if the two of you go through
that class and you still have radical
disagreements about money then you need
more and pre-marriage counseling before
you get married do not marry someone
that you have radical disagreements I
don't think you have a radical
disagreement right now I think you've
got partial information she's got
partial information
and y'all are kind of fumbling around at
this you don't have real good strong
stands on anything and so we'll get you
some strong stands because you'll have
the stuff to talk about as you go
through the class and then you're gonna
have to decide okay we're either not
doing Dave stuff or we're doing Dave
stuff and to do that together both of
you decide we want nothing to do with
this crazy ball headed man or we're
gonna do everything this guy says and
don't do ish hang on Madison will pick
up and I'll pay for you guys to go
through
and help you guys get your life started
right I wish I could have gone through
that class sharing I about killed each
other over the stuff